My name's Jeff Kember and I do
come from the visual effects
industry.
I was most recently
a CD supervisor,
and I speak VFX and cloud.
So really happy
to be here today.
I'm going to be giving a talk
on Google Cloud Storage options
and just what it all is.
When I joined Google,
I wasn't quite exactly
100% clear on all the
different storage options
and how they worked
and why you'd use them.
I'm also going to
talk a little bit
today about getting your data
to the cloud and how that looks.
So from a Google Cloud
Storage options standpoint,
Google Cloud Storage
is a giant block store.
So if you have
onset data-- let's
say you've gone and shot a
huge amount of imagery onset
and you want to
put it somewhere,
the standard storage is
a great place to put it.
It's super-low latency, it's
almost limitless in size,
and it's $0.026 a gig so
it's really inexpensive.
We have a less expensive option
for $0.02, which is the Durable
Reduced Availability Storage.
So what does that mean
to the VFX community?
That means that the latency
is increased a tiny bit.
That's a really great place
to park a significant amount
of data that you
want to be able to do
read-and-write operations for.
If you want to be able to copy
this data to a file system,
if you want to be able
to copy it to local SSD
as on VMs, which we will
talk about in a few minutes,
if you actually want to do
transcoding or rendering
work loads against this, DRA is
a great place to put the data.
We'll also talk a little later
about Nearline storage, which
is our archiving solution,
and go forward from there.
As far as storage on
the actual machines go,
when you spin up a VM, you
have a few different choices
on how you want to get the data
available to the machine you
want to run it on.
So this slightly
complicated diagram here
talks about persistent disk.
PD stands for persistent disk.
It's network storage,
and it's available
both with enterprise-level
spinning disk
as well as with SSD.
And we configure them
in 10-terabyte sizes.
We also have local SSD
attached to the machines,
and that is next generation.
It's super fast.
Think of it less
as a SATA option
and more of a PCIE option.
It's almost 700,000 IOPS and
it's 1.5 terabytes of capacity.
So that's crazy fast.
Instead of thinking
of it as fast disk,
we think of it more
as slow memory.
It's about the speed
of DDR2 memory.
So if you want to deliver
something like a ZFS file
system, for instance,
you can spin up a VM,
throw a ZFS on it, attach 1.5
terabytes of storage to it,
and now you're serving up 1.6 to
1.7 terabytes of data at memory
speeds, at line rates.
That's about 8 gig per
second on the file system.
You can also attach 10 terabytes
of PD to that, as well.
So that's a really
meaty little file system
that you can put up,
which is open source,
and you're only
paying for the VM.
If you have raw
camera data and you
want to perform transcode
operations, for instance,
on it, you can store it on PD.
You can also copy it
over to local SSD.
So the use cases
I've identified here
are transcoding, fluid
simulations, Nuke, ZFS,
Read Cache.
So we have customers
who want to do
fluid simulation on the cloud.
And from a storage
standpoint, they'll
copy the alembic data
and the scene data over,
they'll do the Naiad or Bifrost
or RealFlow fluid sim on it.
But they'll use the
super-high I/O capabilities
of that machine to be able
to write all the cache data.
So the point is that with local
SSD you can get really high ops
and you don't have to worry
about using any network
bandwidth to do it.
I've had as much as 30%
of my simulation time
be eaten up by copying
files across the network
to an Isilon.
Not that the Isilon wasn't fast.
It was just, that's 20
to 40 gigs per frame
of data you're moving, and that
does impact simulation times.
So from a network
connection standpoint,
we've talked significantly about
how many points of presence
Google has and how strong
the Edge network is.
The bigger issue is, as visual
effects companies and media
companies, how do you get
your data onto the cloud.
So we have several
different options.
We have customers who
light up dark fiber
between their location and
a peering location for us.
We have customers who will work
with a partner such as Sohonet,
where they'll buy a
10-gig interconnect.
And they'll only pay for one
gig to the outside world.
But they'll be able to get
a much higher bandwidth
connection to Google and just
pay a fractional increase,
not what the full
load would be if you
wanted to have that go
to the outside world.
Google also has a
VPN offering, which
is a fully managed
solution, which can
deliver gigs of connectivity.
The nice thing
about that solution
is, you just tell us what
you Juniper or Cisco box you
have on premises, or other.
And we have a profile
that works for it.
It's managed.
It just works.
And if you want to run
commercial or private queuing
software, that all
works over the VPN.
It's just an extension
to your network.
So as far as the
transcoding workload goes,
so the green represents
you're on premises or on set.
And this is a copy-to-Google
cloud storage.
So you put in the
punch ECS, and you
can park all the data there.
When you want to run a
transcode workload on it,
you can spin up VMs using
FFmpeg, just open source.
We can also work with
PandaStream and Zencoder.
A local SSD is really the
secret sauce for this.
Because of the
signature of the job,
there's a huge amount of
random reads and writes
that occur in a transcode.
So you can spin up a 8-, 16-,
32-core VM and run multiple
transcodes in parallel.
And then you can write
all that data out to disk,
and the local SSD will
handle that for you.
If you want to run
more, we have customers
who are using a
product like Deadline.
Or you can use pipeline
effects, Cube or Tractor,
or your own queuing system.
The cool part about that
is that the queuing system
will spin up the VMs,
copy the data from GCS
over to the local SSD, unpause
the job, run the transcode,
and then, after
the job's finished,
copy all the data back
to GCS, which is here,
and then spin the VMs down.
So you only pay
for what you use.
You can go massively
parallel with it.
We've had customers who
have 5,000 hours of content
that they want to transcode.
In this example,
it was all German.
And then they needed to be able
to deliver it for distribution.
And they were used to having
a 7- to 12-day delivery cycle.
And we said to them, well,
how many hours you have?
And we got the file
sizes and figured
what the longest transcode was.
We were able to deliver
the job in just over a day.
That was the longest transcode.
So we just ran it all
parallel, all at once.
And it was the
same cost to them,
whether it would be just
over a week or a day.
That was one of the
nice things about that.
So you've parked it
on DRA at this point.
So it's on Durable Reduced
Availability Storage.
So it's the same system as
GCS, but again, slightly higher
latency.
But you've already
done your copy,
you've already
done the transcode,
you've put it back to DRA.
At this point, you can
push it out to the network.
You can use one of our
partners like Fastly
if you need to use a CDN.
If you just want to deliver
it to another provider
and they're going to handle the
distribution, this is your out.
Now, you still want to, of
course, retain this data.
So now you can put
it on Nearline.
So the magic part with Nearline
is, it's $0.01 per gig.
So again, on the
far left-hand side,
we've gone from GCS at
$0.026 to DRA at $0.02 a gig,
and again, as much reading
and writing as you want.
And then, when you move
it over to Nearline,
that becomes a $0.01 per
gig place to store it,
and it can live there as
long as you want it to.
If you wish to read
that data back,
it's going to cost
you $0.01 to do so.
So the nice thing about
this is that the data
is available to you
almost instantly.
The latency from first read to
byte is two to five seconds.
So it's not hours,
it's just seconds.
It comes back extremely quickly.
I'll have a little slide with
some more details on that.
But we have customers who will
put their data in Nearline
and they'll store it there.
If they wish to do operations
on it, instead of being worried
about how many times
I'm going to read it
and how many times do I get
charged that one-cent fee,
they just flip the switch
and move it back to DRA.
And it sits in DRA
and they perform
all the reroute operations
on it for weeks or months,
potentially.
I realize I can't
give historical data,
as Nearline is still
very new for us.
But those are the use cases that
we are using, moving forward
with it.
So the compute engine
we're running on
is really exciting
for me in the fact
that it's crazy-high
performance.
You are only paying
for what you use.
The real differentiator for us
is the local SSD performance
for the transcode, for
the simulation workloads.
From a storage standpoint,
this previous transcoding slide
that I had, it's
the same work case
if you want to run Nuke
jobs, for instance.
If you've already rendered the
image in the cloud, it's there.
And you parse the Nuke
file when you submit it
through your scheduler.
Only the elements
that have changed
are going to be uploaded.
And you're able to benefit
from the super-high-I/O output
of the local SSD drives that are
physically attached to the VMs.
So we have customers who
are using Nuke on this.
We have customers who
are using FluidSIMs.
They have, for
their proprietary,
Fire systems that run
on top of our systems.
And again, all of them are using
this really high-I/O storage.
And what it does for them is
saves their on-premises file
system.
I'm sure if anyone has run
large rendering systems, where
you have tens of
thousands of cores
and you have a significant
amount of compute happening,
if you load your file system
up with a large amount of I/O
for a FluidSIM or any
other type of simulation
or compositing workload with
deep data, where you're looking
at an order of magnitude
more data per element,
you're in a scenario
where that file system
performance can degrade.
And then you start
starving out your CPUs.
And as soon as that
happens, you have
to start throttling one and
favoring another and such.
If you move the high-I/O
workloads to Google Cloud
Platform, you don't have to
worry about your file system
performance on premises.
You can focus on having
100% of your machines
running renders or
a smaller percentage
running comp and sim
jobs, but you're not
negatively impacted by that.
So as far as Nearline
storage as a slide goes,
this details a little bit more
of the relevant information.
So it's $0.01 per gig to store
it, which is super inexpensive.
It's one gig when you read it.
So again, if you want to
read it more than once,
or if you really intend to
be doing operations on it,
you want to put it
on DRA at least,
or GCS, depending on
your latency needs.
We have customers who
are excited that, OK,
hear the $0.01 and
they're like well, OK,
so everything's $0.01 now.
You're like, well,
no, it's really
$0.02 if you want to
do operations on it
and $0.01 if you want
to park it somewhere.
There is a one-month minimum
charge to put it there.
So it's priced in such a
way that it is not intended
for production workloads.
But it's priced in
such a way that it's
intended to be used for
ultra-long-term storage.
Another nice aspect of
being able to use Nearline
as an archiving
tool versus tape is,
you're going to make two
to three copies on tape,
and then you have to
transport them and store them,
and you had to pay for the
robot and someone to run it,
and then you have to
track and manage and deal
with all of this.
The nice thing is you
can modify the size
of the footprint of the data
that you've put on Nearline.
So if you take a
400-terabyte show
and you need to
put it somewhere,
then you can throw
it onto Nearline.
And then you can put a pipe
technical assistant on it
to go through and look a shotgun
and figure out what can stay
and what doesn't have to.
And you can reduce
the size of the show.
I've had shows that
were 400-plus terabytes
and we've reduced them down
to 225 terabytes on disk,
because of course we
didn't backup the temp
files, obviously.
But you go through
and you figure out
you don't need 17
versions of Character X.
And you don't need a whole
bunch of temporary MARI archives
that were 250 gigs apiece.
You can go through
and say, we only
use these two and
these were live
and these are the
latest versions.
So the ability to change
the footprint of the archive
really affects the long-term
storage cost as well as
the organization of the project.
So you can see it's
super-high durability.
The retrievals are fast.
They're only a couple
seconds to get the data back.
I'm sure everyone here
has done restores or made
restore requests.
And you've waited anywhere
from a couple of hours
to go and get that tape
and load it in the robot
and restore a 20-gig
character archive.
And then you realize, oh,
well, that texture was actually
borrowed from over here so you
have to do a second pass to get
the data back.
Or you restored a
significantly larger portion
than what you needed
because you wanted
to make sure you got it all.
The nice thing
with this solution
is you can traipse through
the file structure,
grab the files you
need, and just bring
them online right now.
And the fact that
the more you store,
the higher the throughput is.
So those customers
with large pipes,
if they have hundreds of
terabytes or petabytes of data
store, they have a
significant throughput
and it's predictable.
And they know what the
cost is going to be,
and our APIs are known.
From a pricing standpoint, both
the compute and the storage
have been heading
down with Moore's Law.
So you can see our
curve from 2006 to 2015.
It's continuing to
go in that direction.
So customers who've been using
our Ivybridge technology,
we've rolled out Haswell
in a number of our zones,
and we're continuing to update
and refresh our hardware.
In that context, you're able to
get the increased performance
at not the same cost
but at a lower cost,
as we continue to
reduce our costs,
as well as increase our storage
capacities and availability.
So from just an overall use case
standpoint, with Google Cloud
Storage most customers
here are going
to be putting their data on
GCS from an upload standpoint
and parking it there.
And then they're going
to be spinning up
VMs as file systems.
And they're going to use ZFS,
or they're going to use Avere,
or they going to use Gluster.
Avere is here to talk today.
They're a fantastic solution
that most everyone in the room
knows about.
They have it on prem.
Our cloud offering is excellent.
You can have
between 3 and 30 VMs
and it can scale
larger than that.
You get to use our fast,
low-latency network fabric,
and you're able to use our
persistent disk SSD based
for the back-end storage.
So we are able to serve
up file systems that
are capable of having tens
of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of cores point
at them simultaneously
and be able to deliver that
throughput that you need
at a really high read rate.
It's also very nice to be able
to have something like Avere,
in the fact that you can use it
as simply a caching appliance.
So you don't have
to pre-populate it
if you don't want to.
You can spin it up
and read through it.
And then the data is cached.
Your hit rates are high.
For smaller jobs
that are potentially
hundreds of machines, you can
point at a ZFS file system.
And Bjorn Leffler, the engineer
who did our ZFS file system
is here today to
answer any questions
you may have about that.
He's in the blue shirt at the
back of the room waving hello.
It's exciting in
the fact that it
can stand up to hundreds
of machines hitting it.
It'll deliver eight gig
per second all day long.
And as I mentioned before,
it's backed by our local SSD.
You can also have
multiple ZFS file systems.
You have your texture
on one, and you
can have your alembic
data that churns
a little bit on the
other, and you can point
multiple mount points at it.
So feel free to come
and talk with me
after, or Bjorn, about
some of the different VFX
workloads for storage.
Happy also to
answer questions you
might have about getting
the data to the cloud.
Just to wrap up here,
putting the data on GCS,
spinning up a file
system to be able to run
compute loads against it.
Once you've completed
your compute loads,
if you were on a
file system, you
can put it back
on GCS to park it,
or you can copy the local
SSD data back to GCS.
And then you can spin
your file system down
if you don't have
production workloads to run.
And finally, you can use our
network to deliver the data.
And then, once the
show's wrapped,
you can take the data as
you've been finaling the shots,
you can move it off to
Nearline, and the entire show
can sit on Nearline for
as long as you want it to.
Yet you can bring any assets
back online in seconds,
to be able to get at.
And I think everyone can agree
that that's a really useful use
case for storage, being able
to get at a show from six
or eight years ago and be able
to pull those assets online.